I started thinking about all of the
people that I know that I've that I have
a relationship in history with and
people don't know them like I know them
you know I mean Gweneth Paltrow who's
one of my early guests will be when this
comes out you know I've known her since
she was 16 years old
you know she when my wife and I were
first together
Gweneth was living in my guest bedroom
trying to get an agent so I'm gonna be
able to talk to people have a crazy
story yeah yeah but that's just the
beginning
you know whether it's Alec Baldwin and
the time he tried to get me sober on the
beach when I was at the height of my
crazy partying or you know whether it's
Magic Johnson and you know the
reminiscing about the fact that Pat
Riley banned me from staying at the same
hotel as the Lakers I mean it's been 40
years of doing this yeah you know I get
Mike Myers on or I get Chris Pratt on
and we're gonna have a connection and a
history that no one else is gonna have
so we had break down their walls because
a lot of people get reserved you know
where they get kind of like calculators
they're like am I supposed to say this
or not specific and there's that kinship
that friendship that I think is really
important that your your podcast is
gonna bring out a side of people we
haven't really seen but speaking of you
know all those times
wasn't there a story also about you and
Tom Cruise spending the night together
in a stranger's house because I need to
know more about that yeah well the way
you say it makes it more interesting and
all you know it even better story with
just that headline and no context I'm
imagining such places and I'm into any
of them yeah well yeah for sure so no so
what happened was when we were doing the
outsiders where were 18 and 19 years old
it's Francis Ford Coppola the director
goo you know George the Godfather and
Apocalypse Now and the most intense kind
of director imaginable and and he he in
his effort to make us
more authentic as greasers as sort of
tough Tulsa sort of well you know Baha
wrong side of the tracks guys found a a
bunch of different actual greasers who
are now grown up adults and made us go
spend the night and live with them they
came to us at rehearsal I'm like okay so
we're gonna divide you up Rob Tom you
guys are gonna go stay with blue and
Sandy whoever and we just went to this
to their little house and had dinner and
oh my gosh this could have gone very
Dateline special though like you know
these are Tom and I ended up in the
basement in in two cots and we're like
we we don't know these people
I mean netted them really you know you
think Francis Ford Coppola spent a lot
of time that in these people I can tell
you he didn't he was with an espresso
watching some fancy Fellini movie and
yeah that sounds great and went back to
his espresso meanwhile you deliver yeah
there are two o'clock in the morning in
their basement that's amazing it's an
awesome story I will listen to your
podcast for this story alone cuz it's
scary and I would have been like I'm out
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going